press release came out about somebody
announcing the discovery of the largest
galaxy known so this is a spiral galaxy
which is about five times the size of
the Milky Way so truly enormous galaxy
this galaxies grown and the reason why
these galaxies grown is because there
are some new observations of it in the
ultraviolet part of the spectrum using a
satellite called Galax and when you look
in the ultraviolet part of the spectrum
you suddenly see all these outer parts
of the galaxy that actually only emit in
the ultraviolet and not hardly at all in
the other parts of the spectrum and so
suddenly the galaxy got a whole lot
bigger it's in a constellation called
Pavo and if you ask me where that is I'm
completely lost at that point but no
it's it's out there somewhere so here's
the galaxy this is the galaxy which is
now and you can see so this is a
combination of optical and ultraviolet
imaging where the blue colored stuff is
the ultraviolet imaging so you can see
this is blue stuff that stretches off
way into the distance here so this is
the new thing which has made the galaxy
bigger so also sort of integral to the
story is this little guy here which is I
see 4 9 7 0 so what's thought to have
gone on here is that this little guy
probably smashed through pretty much the
middle of this galaxy and in the process
made a bit of a mess and threw bits of
this galaxy out so probably originally
this galaxy was quite a bit smaller but
the just the act of this that LA galaxy
flying through it or flying past it at
high speed stirred things up a lot and
threw bits of the galaxy out to large
radii which is why it has this large
size now biggest in the universe that's
well that's a big claim right because we
haven't actually seen all the galaxies
in the universe in fact since the
universe probably goes on forever we
never will see all the galaxies in
universe it's just the large as we know
about and in fact in some ways it's sort
of a little bit of a fraud because the
only reason it looks like this at the
moment is because it's relatively
recently been through this process of
having these other little galaxies crash
through it which means it's not in it
actually in an equilibrium situation
there's bits of it getting flung out and
we're seeing it in the process of
getting flying out into space so if we
came back in a billion years time those
bits would probably have gone off on
their own sweet way and the galaxies
would have settled down to something
more normal and small again what this
does seem like a shape to me this seems
a bit like me crashing my car and the
debris of my car going over 60 or 70
meters and then me saying I have the
biggest car in the world exactly so
that's really the story here that what
you're seeing here is a car wreck in the
process of happening and that's why it's
spread over the wreckage you spread over
such a large area the reason why the
ultraviolet is interesting is because it
tells you about you star stars that are
forming now
because very young stars I met lots of
lots of ultraviolet light so where you
see lots of ultraviolet that's telling
you that stars are forming and that's so
that's also a bit peculiar about this
galaxy because it means it's forming
masses and masses of stars far away from
the center and in fact they've even done
a study to look at the relative ages of
stars as you work your way outwards and
what they find is that as you work your
way out the stores get younger and
younger so it looks like this
interaction with these little galaxies
here has actually sort of sent a wave of
star formation out through these
galaxies but actually the reason I'm
excited about this galaxy isn't actually
the galaxy itself at all the reason I
find this a fascinating picture is
because as well as this galaxy is that's
sort of the focus of the story it
actually illustrates something about
galaxy formation and galaxy evolution
there's a galaxy here which is in the
process of dying and there's a galaxy
here which is in the process of being
formed in the first place
so the galaxy that's in the process of
dying is this little guy from the index
catalog which caused all the trouble in
the first place and you can see it's
basically it's very sort of a boring
looking galaxy at this point it's not
actually forming any new stars itself
that's because this process of its
smashing through this bigger galaxy
stripped all its gas out so it actually
stopped forming stars at that point so
this guy is now sort of at the end of
its life as a star-forming galaxy it's
turned into one of these things called
an S 0 galaxy so that's sort of the end
of the life of a galaxy but if you look
way out here in the outskirts there's
this little faint blue blob out here
which sort of is connected to the the
end of this spiral feature in this
galaxy and this is what's thought to be
a thing called a tidal dwarf this is a
galaxy which is a brand-new system so
it's very you know so meeting all these
ultraviolet light so we know it's
forming lots of new stars and it's
actually being formed in the process of
this collision and we'll probably kind
of escape entirely from this system and
form a little galaxy all on its own so
this is a galaxy we see in this process
we see the death of one galaxy the end
of one galaxy star formation and the
birth of a brand new one out here